so then last one where was it shot it
was obviously a track somewhere was this
LA or it was redondo beach okay yeah
right is a really nice track and it
looks like it thankfully we didn't get
kicked out we did a guerilla style yeah
we had to you know but thankfully when
you're shooting with an iphone i have a
feeling feeling well i would say would
be low profile but if you would see the
rig we used to fill this thing so it
would be stable as it's this huge like
plastic hexagon with all these weird
articulating arms and attachments for
microphones and bounce cards and
craziness thing probably weighed almost
like 25 30 pounds of porch at estate
wing around you figure that that would
be low profile but no not really so
people just left us alone I guess they
thought we're doing a school project or
something yeah right so when in doubt no
it's funny because one time we went to
shoot we came there in the morning and
we saw the sides or we saw the location
paperwork for 92 and oh no that's right
out there the night before and they did
it like legit you know yeah shut down
the street they got permits yeah and
we're like so shouldn't take my so at
least we know that we have a good
location the other shows want yeah we
shot wherever no no to it it takes place
yeah well did you have any code words or
did you have sort of a plan B if you saw
you know whatever no you would disperse
and meet at the secret spot or something
pretty much it was Jack me like a good
idea that's a great that's really good
all we had was every man for themselves
i would usually blurt out a vulgarity
and run is what i would do it's pretty
much my flight or fight or flight
mechanism you weren't running that fast
that's true i fell a lot of it but i
hope we did have one guy that I honestly
thought that we were caught this guy
just started following us when we were
shooting and I eventually went up to him
because he on the director I gotta
figure out if this is a staff from the
school or whatever and it was just some
weird guy that was following us like I
you seem tired I do remove sim I totally
forgot all about this guy he just was
enthralled with what are you guys doing
I what do you do I was like this is the
teacher or principal or
whatever and wasn't it you somewhere
doubt it Jesse a was a little a little
bit of an oddball her just kind of like
what you guys doing I won't watch you
make them from them are you famous
you're making a movie haha an iphone
yeah so that was probably the closest
that we got to our location being
compromised yeah did you allow him to
watch or found out he was a clown on the
side I put tournament do an extra hey I
think we shot him as he walked away just
like you get some very similar to to the
entire thing so yeah
you